&gt;&gt; Thank you Andy, I am going the other way as the testing is about to begin.
&gt;&gt; Alright contestants, you know the rules. Place the appropriate cup on the paper
in the right place with the appropriate category. Ready, go.
&gt;&gt; This is really exciting. Wow Andy you're right look at Alex tasting all those
samples. This is just amazing.
&gt;&gt; It really is amazing Lauren but you know you can't actually see her tasting.
&gt;&gt; I know Andy but it's just the thought of all those taste buds being activated
and how fast she's processing all of these flavors it's just it's just
incredible.
&gt;&gt; You're right, and look at that. It looks like we have a winner. I, well, the
ref is checking the responses now.
&gt;&gt; We have a winner!